now let's take a look at how we actually
conduct uh variant calling on some data
so first we will go to the tbionfor
platform where we will find in areas of
analysis section so in this areas of
analysis you can see there are many
different sections related to
transcriptomic genomic metagenomic and
other kinds of data here we will look
for mutation variance section if you
hover over the eye icon you will get
more information you can see that this
one is going to be appropriate for exam
sequencing data if we go within this
section just click on the title
we will be prompted to upload data this
data can come from ncbi
from our computer or from the ftp
account if you have a research account
with us but for now we will use the demo
option so we will click on this drop
down and here let's select this last
example for breast cancer mutation so
let's
click on this link and what you should
see is an interface for the pipeline
builder you will only get an option to
select something that is highlighted and
you can see that the first thing that is
highlighted is the start button
here you will have a little bit of
information about what this pipeline is
all about and it's going to be about
finding variance in this data now once
we've started we have our next option to
select and that is bow tie two in each
one of these steps you will get
information about the algorithm and
briefly what bow tie two does is it
hashes all of the sequences of the reads
that we have in our fastq file arranges
them so that it is quick to find the
most appropriate position on the
reference genome based on the matching
sequence
now you can also click on input files
and you can see what we have to upload
to be able to use this section and this
includes a fastq file for each one of
the samples that we have and we have
several samples here it will also have a
link to the reference genome this is
important because you can see that each
one of the files that we originally
uploaded is an sra format s array is a
format to compress raw fastview files
because they are so large
after we've mapped our reads onto the
reference genome what we get is a bam
file or a sam file that contains the
information about each read and the
position on the genome where this read
aligns to we can visualize this data so
let's click on visualization
and here you can look at input files and
you can see that we have the fast q
files but also these sam files and like
i said
fast you files are reads
just their sequences in random order and
the sam file is when they are organized
also by position on the reference genome
so after we have visualized the data we
also want to determine whether any
variance can be called on the collection
of reeds that fall in a specific region
and for that we will use free base
freebase is a haplotype-based variant
detector and it's a tool that works
really fast it takes in the bam files
which is already the reads that have
been aligned to the reference genome it
looks at how many reads contain a
specific change from the reference to be
able to call that a variant
now the output file if you click here is
going to be a vcf and that is the vcf
that we will later work with to
determine whether any of the variants
are actually clinically relevant
now let's click on end
okay after your page reloads you will
click here on the visualization button
the visualization opens up in jbrowse
and jbrowse is a software that allows
you to visualize the same file the index
genome
and actually look through the different
output files that we have in the
pipeline so here down below you have
what's called mapping statistics it
tells you how many of the reads were
paired how many aligned correctly and
how many aligned incorrectly and also
gives you an overall alignment rate so
you can see that for each sample
we have an alignment rate and it's very
good it's over 97
so that means that the alignment worked
really well
one of the samples is a little bit below
that 96.76
but that is still pretty good now here
on the side you will have multiple
tracks you can open these tracks let's
just take one sample and then you can
also look at the vcf file for variant
calling which means that it will only
show us whether a certain position is a
variant as you scroll through
you will find that some segments have no
reads at all and others will have some
read so here each bar like this
represents a read so let's try searching
for a gene one important gene
in cancer is p53 p53 is the name of the
protein and the name of the gene is tp
53
as you type it in here you can then
select the gene and now you will see
that this particular gene has a lot of
reads aligned to the reference so over
hovering over each position you will
have the count of total reads that are
actually mapped to this region
down here you will have your
gene
in the gtf file so we'll display all of
the transcripts that are available for
this gene the thick bars are exons and
the lines are introns or non-coding
regions
you can see that approximately the
accumulation of reeds corresponds
to the exons that we have even though it
is not precise
in the middle you can see the
information about each one of the
variants and you can see that there are
different kinds
single nucleotide variant
substitution
insertion
here you will have an information
about this specific
variant that is identified for example
for this insertion you can see
that
t-a-c-a-a
turned into t-a-c-a-a-c-a-a
so we have an additional three
nucleotides that were inserted in this
position